hey guys we're back to analyze our round
eight games from yesterday and it's 1
p.m. in Romania the next round starts at
2 p.m. so we're gonna try and keep this
brief even though we both had games
lasting over 50 moves right know you
want to start with my game yeah I was
playing a low rated player I had lost
the previous two games so I was trying
to just stop the bleeding and come back
with a win I didn't manage to win this
game but I did manage to draw I was
playing a much lower rate of player I
don't even know his rating I don't think
I even checked maybe around 2000 give or
take and I played a first of all I was
expecting d4 and I was planning to play
g6 against d4 he surprised me with a 4
and I still play g6 and we okay we got
kind of a new position compared to what
I'm used to playing I just wanted
something dynamic and that's essentially
what I got this is actually a similar
setup to my round 2 game where my
opponent played kind of this early early
like Bishop d3 but my around 2 opponent
had played c3 early in this game
my opponent played d5 and this was
already a new position for me
resembling some kind of like benoni type
structure i play the move here I was
slightly inspired by by Ben Feingold who
likes to play like this what do we call
it the check Pannonia the biruni wall
with this structure with E 5 thinking
that if the center stays closed I have
future plans that maybe f5 and attacking
but my opponent took calm passant I took
back I was very pleased and it seems
like every game I've played this
tournament I've had like a very
comfortable opening if not some
advantage from early on yeah and then at
least with the recent games I haven't
been able to capitalize on the
advantages this game included I mean if
we see what happened I just completed
development my opponent
playing slowly with c3 and h3 I played
to e5 and after take I played well I
thought was the best move Queen take d5
but maybe given what happened in the
game I should have taken with with a
bishop or something I wanted to take
with the Knights but this allows Knight
g5 yeah which is kind of annoying so I
took with the Queen and this has to be
at least at least better for black looks
White's almost nothing's developed on
the Queen side and black has almost
everything developed and then he played
Bishop f1 and he's just trying to
equalize essentially he wants to trade
Queens complete development and the
problem is it's like quite symmetrical
pawn structure so if he's able to get
maybe two or three moves to complete
development then the it might be a hard
position to win I really didn't want to
trade Queens here I wanted to play
something like Queen h5 but then he can
essentially force a trade with my g5 and
yes I've I trade the Queen's rook take
t1 rook 88 and I'll say again I haven't
checked with the engine so I I'm not
sure if I played I'm sure I didn't say
the right way to maximize my advantage
but I wasn't sure what to do here in the
game and this is probably this will
probably be a valuable position to look
back on and see like how I could have
improved yeah I've started with h6 I
wanted to prevent Bishop g5 or Knight g5
and going forward here white did
complete development
I played Bishop d5 Knight c4 and I
wanted to imbalance a position in some
way so I took on f3 which I thought
maybe is a controversial move because I
give up the bishop pair by do damage his
King side pawn structure so I thought
okay maybe you'll have potential for
later ideas like putting it 9 + f4 or
playing some day like 95 targeting f3
not so okay the game continues then here
I wasn't sure what to do because it
seems like my pieces are good like how
to improve and then I found an
interesting
yeah that it's kind of a weird concept
to try and trade the dark sweet bishops
even though his Dartford bishop is
undeveloped if I can trade off the
bishops that I could potentially access
that for so I was happy with the move I
found here at kini h7 ideas of either
Bishop f6 Bishop g5 or h5 and Bishop h6
and now 33 right oh that's another thing
I wanted to play Knight c3 after a for
right
the problem is yeah he can take on on
age six yeah that's probably just bad he
as a bishop care so yeah was a was a
potential tactic in the position but
yeah King u7 so maybe multi-purpose move
he plays by 52 and then I kind of regret
my next move I played Bishop f6 I'm
thinking I should have played h5 the
difference is after Bishop f6 he plays
f4 and he just stops my plan and I
thought initially his pawn is weak on f4
but it actually strengthens his position
it opens up this diagonal for the
LightSquared bishop right and I can't
achieve the trade if I played h5 and he
plays that for I could still play Bishop
h6 yeah and then this would be great
yeah yeah and this is one thing which I
learned in childhood that in most middle
games two nights are better than night
in Bishop you heard of that no no
sometimes an endgame it's different but
in the middle game like they can
coordinate better because they can
target different squares I guess it
always depends on the position but this
is just kind of general terms yeah so
it's another reason to try and trade the
darks for bishops but going forward here
he played that for and then I felt like
okay I'm probably not better it's
probably still balanced plate rook d7
Bishop e2 not a bad move threatening
Bishop g4 I played Bishop GA they wanted
maneuver to c7
Bishop g4 f5 Bishop f3 Bishop c7 I
wanted to pressure that for pawn
he defended that for plan with tactics
rook t1 so now I can't take because
issues on the the D file so I play rook
ft8
I was still feeling okay here I felt
like I was building a pressure and then
then he made things complicated he
played ninety five attempting to defend
the F on try and maybe transform the
pawn structure and I essentially have to
take on on e5 I spent a while here do I
take with the knight do I take with the
bishop I really didn't want to take with
the bishop because then he has two
bishops versus two knights but now I
realize that it offers me good chances
after take take and Knight to e7 this is
what happened the game i unleashed the
rook on the D file and now the e4 pawn
is weak and if he were able to get the
pawn to f4 the position might be
different but he doesn't really have
time for that so I was feeling good here
I mean he played Bishop f4 defending the
pawn and now I completely mishandled the
position I play the move which I thought
is just the obvious like go-to move here
I played g5 which i think is just just a
clear mistake given what happened
I should have very simply taken on on d1
if we trade rooks
I mean this would be great for me then I
play g5 and maybe some at some point f4
and then walk my king and win the pawn
right there very solid here yeah no that
would be great position his two bishops
aren't that powerful there yeah and if
he takes with Bishop on g1 I'm sure I
still have like defy or g5 some nice
positional play so they missed is that
after I play g5 he doesn't have to move
his bishop he just gets some annoying
initiative and actually for the next
next several moves he just leaves a
bishop at four no he starts with rook
take g7 ripped 87 another intermediate
movie six and this is just something I
overlooked like I was playing a weaker
player I wasn't expecting him to like be
ambitious and counter-attack yeah very
straight forward exactly yeah
yeah I play rook to e3 so now both his
bish
they're hanging but now he simply takes
on c6 I saw this line I actually I
calculated this line when I played g5 I
saw that we would reach this position I
just assumed he would maybe retreat to
e3 and then I would play rook t5 yeah
and I was feeling good about this
because c4 can mean that with rookie 5
rookie 5 is a threat anyway my King's
gonna walk in and attack the pawn and
maybe at some point I can play a 6 and
c4 and put my pawns on light squares
well I missed he has a much stronger
move here Bishop e8 and it's incredible
but he just keeps initiative I have to
defend a7 only way is to move to a pawn
actually after I played a6 I offered a
draw because I realized I'm in big
trouble
just miscalculated he of course declined
the draw he plays Bishop a7
yeah ambitious and he's just clearly
better so it's incredible like such a
good opening and then I mishandled some
like one complicated slightly
complicated moment and now I'm just just
about lost in the end game as well
really unfortunate I feel like that's
happened a lot this tournament like I've
missed some critical moments and
sometimes all it takes is a couple
oversights to lose a game but this game
I fought on and this game I I knew that
I have in nights nights are tricky and
I'm not gonna give up so easily
yeah so first of all I can't I can't
save my pawn because then I lose my
Knights you seven will come so I had to
sack the C pawn I'm taking g6
you take snipe psyching up six and I
think his technique was pretty good for
the next few moves but then later he
stumbled so going forward Bishop d4
brings the rook to e5 he wants to win a
six I've no way to defend a six so I
tried to get counter play rook a5 rook
d1 king h2 and my counter play is all
about exploiting the team on each two
and miraculously I found some nice
coordination I start with rook e1 I want
to win the east
spawn so we trade but now it just seems
like he can start pushing the queenside
pawns yeah that's what he does before
and then it like at first glance it
seems pretty hopeless because like b5 is
coming and it seems like he's relatively
solid on the Kings side but I found some
nice kind of mechanism to coordinate my
knight in my rook to exploit this King
so I start with King h5 I want to get my
King off this six rink because I'm
expecting b5 after he plays b5 I play
this this nice move rook e1 and one of
the key points is that if he takes on c6
I can play rook e6 back and I just win
the C pawn like he can't advance cuz
it's pinned yeah and that would slow him
down enough where I would still have
chances to to survive so he played the
natural move here b6
oops b6 and I try and slow him down that
play rook e1 preventing b7 and then he
played what I thought was a strong move
but I pretty sure this move is just a
mistake
rook a5 I thought it was strong at first
because he has some tricky ideas of like
rook b5 sure he also is preventing
Knight f5 which is one of my key sources
of counter play so this might be a good
exercise for people like black to move
and find the the most troublesome move
for white to deal with due to time
constraints I'll just show it
Knight to g6 I simply want to come to h4
and if I can come to h4 + f3 there's
this potential for some at least some
perpetual check yeah so here it was
interesting what happened yeah he played
rook a 7 I played night h4 and then he
played a5 and offered me to draw knowing
that I have perpetual check right so
well at some point we might go back and
see
how like he could have tried to win and
now like on a normal day I would
probably just accept the job because
okay there it's gonna be perpetual check
but there's doesn't look like there's
any way to win however because he was
pretty low on time at this point and I
had some momentum going in my direction
like he probably missed this whole this
whole sequence of 9h for I wanted to
play it for a win I saw one trap in the
position which was risky but I went for
it just hoping for some further miracle
I played nine of three following the
advice had been fine gold always repeats
and then I played rook a1 and so weird
waiting move well there's a couple traps
with this move the basic trap I was kind
of hoping for a c4 where he's attacking
my rook that walks into my a3 with a
fork that was kind of just hope but I
was also hoping for b7 which looks like
the most natural move right but now I'm
pretty sure black just meets by force oh
wow so black to move pretty sure it's
just made in four one two one two three
four and this you have to find before
the next round starts
wait so with with rook b1 you didn't
have this mate but you only have it I
only have it yeah after b7 v 7 should
already be a clue b7 inhibits his rook
oh let's think Oh so night of three
check g4 and there's no red g7 yes yeah
it's a nice this was like the one hope
in the position yeah I think it was a
price to play on cuz I mean this right
I'm pretty sure broke eight ones a
losing move though but I played it just
because I was hoping for this scenario
where he's like he can queen but rook g1
is unstoppable so I'm like I'm pretty
sure he would like he was he saw it like
you saw that when he move it he was
scared to play it really he just wants
to pawn zombie six the the idea for a
way he just wants to like escape with
the king I
the move to play is just at three mm-hmm
it's a scary move to play he had like
two minutes left
yeah but his queenside pawn is so close
to promoting and okay there's some
complicated variations after I wouldn't
take on a three I would play rook after
two first king g1 and I take a three
King F 1 and D 2 or something yeah so
rook t2 threatening kind of this classic
classic perpetual check I've shown this
in like a st. Louis chess club lecture
like this exact idea but then he can
play Bishop f2 and I think it's just I
mean I don't think there's quick enough
counter play for black I would have
tried to find resources from here but
what about King age for king h4 in this
position probably Bishop f2 check then
take on h3 b7
there's no as Bishop is such a strong
defensive piece maybe I could still like
trying repeats but his King just runs to
the Queen side one yeah no but you have
you have work D to anyway so after b7
mm-hmm you're saying rip t2 here ah
because I'm controlling g2 yes
interesting so be a queen it's just
perpetual check yeah Wow hmm maybe I
would have found this are there any
other resources especially b1 still
manage to check maybe bishops g13 oh
sorry this isn't helpful
kingi really Oh King g3 threatening
perpetual oh right right do you want
that's really nice yeah
this is what I was hoping for yeah I
mean you get a lot like his work is so
bad yeah where his rooks completely out
of play and my King night in Rupp can
coordinate so okay maybe I've three it
would like it would have been
complicated I'm really curious to see
what the engine would have said you know
I think maybe he could have played a
three earlier - right like he like even
in this position stuff is 85 right but
it's a game to analyze he was pretty
upset with with the draw actually what
happened in the game I really didn't
want to draw I didn't show the end of
the game so I played rookie one hoping
he would like play p7 and get mated he
didn't play v7 he didn't play off three
he played rook c7 which is just putting
his rook on about her threatening b7 I
repeat I still didn't want to draw I was
trying to like I was using all my time
trying to find some potential mating
ideas I played c5 just to kill a move
and he took and then I repeated me drew
now after the game he was like going
back and showing like he was saying I
don't think he spoke me much English but
he was saying like he should have won at
some point but he wasn't able to show
like a clear line like he was showing
some like he was showing b7 I showed him
this meeting idea so right
anyway I survived at this point I'm not
in the running for any like prize or or
any prestige I'm just trying to play
decent games try and have some instruct
instructive moments yeah you on the
other hand well playing for some big big
amount of Lee yeah I managed to win in
round round 8 I was playing um 2160 I
think um w FM or maybe W I am not sure
so she only plays Neider so I went for a
four that's nice if they're gonna do the
Sicilian I'm happy do you think your
opponents are aware that you wrote a
book on open Sicilian I think some of
them are I think a lot of them are not
yeah especially because you're four in
here right and and my database is like
Aldi for exactly but yeah I'm really
familiar with the h3 lines I like them a
lot nice so she kind of played I don't
know
natural knight or moves actually in 97 I
think it's an accurate I feel like
blacks should try to put the bishop on
e6 first but we end up getting a pretty
normal position and I played this move a
four here which is very instructive move
I'm just trying to push the pawn to b3
and then I'll kick the night and then
once the night goes back I'll I'll come
in with 95 nice and I think what just
gets a better position here mm-hmm
so rook c8 d3 and here I think she
realized she's getting worse so she kind
of lashes out with h5 which i think is
just dubious I advanced h4 knight of
fate so her ideas to put the man on g6
and target the h4 pawn I was thinking I
might have something but like f4 you
know looks really natural but but Bishop
g4 is annoying and then rook c3 is a
threat mm-hmm so I wasn't really sure
about this just look it's quite unclear
although I feel like why to be like
Queen d3 here yeah I mean it feels very
nice for white because the you want to
play a 5 and take and take back with
Knights but yeah I don't know maybe 97
95 or 97 you have a 5 and oh the 95
comes with 2 yeah yeah even though I
don't know anyway I the whole game I'm
just trying to keep control right so I
just put my queen on g3 nice I saw that
she has no counter play here f6 I always
take and the knight is hanging mm-hmm
and then if she castles I'll just play
Bishop f3 major part can't be defended
yeah it's nice
so 97 d1 apparently I think I was really
considering this funny move rook 82 just
to defend the C to play Knight
five necks and then white is better I
thought it was hopes I thought it was
too creative I didn't feel like doing
anything special but apparently the
engine likes it mm-hmm
okay riff d1 just piling up on the d6
pawn on d5 square b5 now it's really
thinking about just taking but again I
wasn't so sure about this position
maybe Knight c3 you have ideas of like
rook aid and ninety seven Knights
yeah rook aid is a threat so I also have
a queen d3 threat he or she would have
to Castle but the problems with Queen d3
oh4 pond so she'll give the exchange
take on each floor and just get this
crazy counter play I see so this looked
very clear again I now I play it okay to
and I think my position was much better
at this point finally she castles Bishop
f3 now I want to take on h5 hit the
night and then the bishop on e7 is a big
problem and here she was a huge time
trouble like under 10 minutes
well it seems like full domination for
fights but surprisingly it holds on well
and even gets like equal and better
position Wow so my technique was was bad
time trouble is just so hard oh it's
hard psychologically when your opponent
like then you you you have this internal
conflict you try and play quickly to put
them under more pressure you slow down
to try and find the best moves but you
can give him more time exactly yeah
but yeah like tactically she was holding
on because it's efore pawn is hanging so
I can never take on h5 okay but I just
kept their pressure with every move this
rook b8 rook a seven she trades you've
had so many games where you dominate
like the only open fire is such nice
positional play the only thing only
thing I know how to do it works and I
think I missed my chance around here so
it it's a tough position but apparently
if I had taken on c5
this would have given me the win much
earlier what I didn't realize was that
after Bishop takes h5b for that I can
take on g6 and from afar I didn't
realize that Queen takes e5 not only I
can take this pawn but also I'm hitting
the bishop with Jack so she doesn't have
time to take on c3 what would happen if
fish of take g6 one takes c3 um it takes
on c3 I imagine I can just feel like oh
is there an eye that's six check looks
juicy
yeah like nine of six might be possible
or even I feel like just keeping the
bishop uh-huh it's good all right oh if
black takes on d5 f7 will hang yeah I
take here wise chess space Knight f6 I
have six it's all these scary ideas
minimum just take it widest be meeting
so that was yeah it kind of the clear
win that I missed I instead I play b4
which gives her some counter play
finally I took the pawn and then brick
c8 was a really strong move now if we
trade rooks she gets her Queen to the C
file and a lot of play and I'm not
really creating a lot of threats on the
the King side but I managed to I mean I
played this move Knight d5 here it's
just a practical move because I didn't
want to play like Bishop d2 and have to
deal with like 904 for example where
everything is just kind of hanging or
even Queen c4 and I didn't see what move
I'm making here so I felt like the
trends not going my way I tried to keep
it now I give her a chance to win back
the pawn at the cost of her LightSquared
Bishop and I thought well any endgame
here I'm gonna be very happy with my
bishop on you two hitting b5 dark square
Bishop might be passive of course she
can take on c2 but then I thought okay
two bishops I still have some chances
but she took on c2 right away which i
think is a lot stronger I pull back but
at least I have some
stability in the position of h5 coming
to ya some King side attack so 97 I gave
this check I realized it's unlikely that
she'll take and allow this which looks
really good
this is everything is defended I'm
breaking through but can gauge eight and
I have no no good follow-up 98 would be
a good way to lose the night after like
Queen c6m if only this word bughouse
just asked for a rook yeah any heavy
okay I pull back my g4 and now I mean
she's been playing on the increment for
a while which it's like how is she
surviving this position but okay here I
just started kind of um I think at this
point she still has resources she can
even try to take the b2 pawn and ask me
how I'm gonna meet made her exactly but
she just starts playing I think way to
passively and this gives me some
initiative okay so Queen da Queen g3 I
went back and then finally I pushed h6
right at the moment where g6 I have this
trick with Knight takes e5 nice and so
it's not quite over so I have the maid
on G side of something down six yeah
nine of six I can't take Bishop d7 but
Bishop f4 I think and I didn't see how
black could survive here because I'm
gonna take when back the piece grab
another pawn and maybe Bishop take
before it possible and then leave the
pawn in F 6 cuz the King looks safe on
each 7
Oh like this yeah oh yeah that's true I
guess I would it might lead to some
ending where it's like three on two on
the King side yeah I guess I would
probably take and then try to infiltrate
somehow maybe push the pawn to h7 that's
probably I'll try to get in Queen g5 so
maybe like King King eh Saturn and black
hey thank you can NES just defend the
back rank right oh you can't can you
take on b5 if you take on b5 Queen take
out six
maybe Bach just wants to play Bishop c4
and it's true yeah oh definitely very
tricky but yeah I think objectively she
could have gone for this mm-hmm
but but I think because of this long she
panicked and so she took on g4 which is
probably a clear mistake because now I
just got the lights course that's nice
and it's this night is dominated by the
five fun
yeah Knight and Bishop are both super
passive and I was able to just get in
and that was it that's not a perfect
game not even close but good enough yeah
so that's it for round eight
cool we have round nine in like 30
minutes yeah we should grab a snack and
then we'll do one more video and that
will be the tournament I'll be it so if
you guys oh wait
by the time this is uploaded the
tournament will be down but if you want
to review any of the games you can check
them out we'll have a link in the
description for the live broadcasts just
like everybody yeah alright see you guys